nothing different just the person
changes yeah and then
you get a million views
people think you're funny people think
you're creative and then these people
will go on other platforms like tv will
hit up and like oh maybe they're out
they're really funny they go they're not
a bomb yeah because they found out oh
[ __ ] i have to rest on my own laurels i
didn't develop any of my own content my
own thoughts all i did was scroll every
day and look for something to steal
[Laughter]
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast i am your host
david soh and we have
ed park right here today
funny enough we were just talking about
uh you know before we started rolling
like the perception and i've talked
about this a lot on the podcast but i
feel like sometimes when i say things on
this podcast people think that i'm
saying things from a very hateful place
right
right which understandably so your boys
are haters it's literally half of my
comedy is me just hating on [ __ ] and you
know picking out things that most people
wouldn't find funny and i just hate on
things because it's just a fun thing to
do right
but when i talk about things in social
media
i think i do have somewhat of an idea of
how this works right
and i'm always
um wary for young people who get into
this who wants to do this as a job
because i i have friends who are
elementary school teachers and a lot of
these kids when they write what they
want to be when they grow up they say an
influencer
which is crazy right
and
i'll say it again like i've said it a
million times on this podcast if anybody
out there who wants to do what i do not
so much i do but what you know
influencers do go ahead i say you do it
and try it but i'll tell you it is going
to be one of the most difficult things
that you'll ever do in your life and the
reason why is because
a lot of these influences that you
follow they work jobs too
you know it's not that easy to make
money on this yeah unless you have like
a certain business mind state or you
know how to leverage yourself right so i
mean you were talking about that that
that kid on tick tock right yeah so uh
yeah i saw this video
it is just kind of sad
it is it's just straight up sad like um
it was a tick tock repost you know how
that [ __ ] goes like it's on reddit or
instagram because i'm not on tick-tock
yeah but it was like you know that voice
over when you have two point some
million followers and do a meet and
greet at vidcon right and his point out
she's a pretty girl
and then she flips the camera
and she has nobody in her line yeah you
come meet her and i was like holy [ __ ]
how do you have two million followers
and then at vidcon the the it's like the
comic con of of like youtube instagram
tick to all that for influencers
and nobody knows who you are nobody's
there to actually see you
that
blows my mind like i that's the part
that i don't understand about this so
weird because
short form content and the way that tik
tok is developed and i had a
conversation with somebody and i told
you about this
um
where i literally got into an argument
with somebody who was trying to tell me
how social media works right yeah and
this is somebody who has
tried to be in the entertainment space
since i've met this guy
and been giving him advice because i
really believe that you know he's he's a
funny funny guy and he could do a lot of
great things problem with him is that he
is so stuck in his ways he doesn't
understand how social media works so for
example we got into this you know
argument
which shouldn't have been an argument
and the reason why it became that way
was because he was talking out of his
[ __ ] ass and i didn't want him to
invest his time into stupid [ __ ] so for
example he was like oh i have a friend
who has like 70 000 tick-tock followers
like this guy's mated
yo how sad that is to hear yeah that
[ __ ] is sad i mean that's a lot of
people at a football game yeah
and then i was i was trying to explain
to him i was like listen
i don't know what you mean by made it
and they're like oh because like you
know the guy's famous now and i'm like
no that's not how it works i was like
specifically on the tiktok platform and
i was breaking it down to him and your
example of that is what i'm talking
about tick tock is a very different
social media app where people don't
really become invested into the
individual they just watch and they
scroll and they move on watch scroll
move on watch scroll move on right which
isn't pro which isn't really problematic
it's just how the platform is developed
it's different and so
he was using me as an example he goes
well you have like a million you know
followers on youtube blah blah blah and
like you made it but your views don't
reflect that i was like 100 true yeah
but i'll let you know the difference
people who have watched me on this
channel have been with me since they
were [ __ ] 12.
you know right and they haven't left
right like i walk out till this day and
we make that joke with me and tim like
i'm famous too no like i get recognized
too we just continue the joke yeah so
it's we've grown up with these people
we've created content where we created
an actual connection because this was
long format content it wasn't some quick
joke that you got to move on from
occasionally people might recognize you
from tik-tok here and there but there's
a different type of connection that you
have a lot of companies too don't put
money into people who only have tick
tocks because they know their conversion
rate is terrible they can't sell a
product because people don't care about
your [ __ ] opinions right they just
want to see you make your [ __ ] video
and [ __ ] off do you find it very odd
that a lot of these people who are
tick-tock famous they still live at
their parents house
think about that your favorite
tick-tockers who you think are balling
out of their [ __ ] mind and by the way
i'm not [ __ ] on people who aren't
making big money on tiktok i'm trying to
let people understand that you have to
be passionate about the stuff and
develop the business after that yeah
right so you the passion comes then you
develop something to make money money is
not going to just fall in your [ __ ]
lap yeah right a lot of the most
successful people on this platform who
i've seen have developed a business
platform with their stuff i personally
haven't even done that
you know junebe right
those people are making big banks and so
they kind of look at these top tick
talkers and they go well they made a lot
of money that's you're talking about the
point zero zero zero one percent
who's going to say that's going to be
you so i'm having this conversation with
this guy he's trying to school me
on this thing i've done now for 13 years
yeah
and the guy has been trying for 13 years
and hasn't gone anywhere and it's like
how do you have the audacity to tell me
how the [ __ ] this [ __ ] works
right right and so we got into this
little thing where he was like okay he
goes well most people who watch tick
tocks are you know ages like 30 and
above and i'm like
what where did you get that from so he
started googling this [ __ ] right
and he was like see like people are like
26 to 45 there's a like there's a
certain percentage he goes like i was
like okay
i've had conversations with people at
tick tock right because i got my account
banned twice
right
and i asked them the same question and i
just me trying to explain to them the
difference between age gap of people who
are on tick tock versus engagement right
yeah they're definitely older people who
are on tick tock but they're not the
most engaged and they're not the ones
with the buying power it's usually the
youth he goes that's not what it said on
google they said that ages 26 i was like
listen you're talking about who
downloads the app i'm talking about and
he goes nope you're wrong you just don't
like it when you're wrong he was trying
to sun you mean it's like but then at
the end of the day the proof is in the
pudding
what have you done and what have i done
so at this point i gave up i'm like okay
you know what
since you would rather just sound like
you're right instead of just taking this
thing that yeah i'm substantially
younger than you but i have garnered a
you know decent amount of success on
this
then stay where you're at yeah right
don't ask me for advice anymore don't
ask me for any [ __ ] handouts don't do
this fake little thing where you're
talking about you appreciate all the
hard work i do i don't want to hear any
of this [ __ ] anymore from here on out
you stay in your [ __ ] lane and then
you go ahead and you complain about your
life right and i got tired of people
like that i got really tired of people
complaining to me about their situation
and doing [ __ ] nothing about it and
that's basically what that was it sounds
like those delusional people who think
they're going to make it to the nba yeah
it's like when you play basketball and
that one guy just starts yelling at
everybody on the court it's like you're
not going to go to the nba yeah like
relax relax it's cool
yeah social media is a [ __ ] trip man
and i think for anybody who wants to try
it and get into it do it but you know
garnet like really level your
expectations correctly like know what
you're doing and know what you want out
of this if you want just recognition for
people to watch your videos you can do
that and then not make any money
there's like a few years ago a while ago
like um
i had a friend who worked with like
inner city youth and they had this like
um
like a career seminar
and so they had like restaurant like
chefs people who work in this industry
or that and then she wanted me to come
and talk about you know
video production or entertainment
industry
and then
you know everybody had a chance to talk
and speak about these things like what
they do in the restaurant business what
they do and i don't know as a mechanic
this and that and then for me because
you know i came from the youtube
background at that time and i was
telling them what you know you talk
about what i've done where i've been
whatever
engagement from all these kids
right
and i felt
i don't know how to say this
i felt like
a few
stabbing eyeballs yeah from the other
guys because of what they do but then
the engagement from the kids when i
started talking about video production
and youtube everyone would like want to
know what what it is to do what i do
yeah cause we were saying like you were
saying like so many kids these days just
want to grow up and be an influencer
yeah
right but and even that
title ii of influencer what the [ __ ] is
that yeah what does it mean like
influence you to what
what right buy [ __ ] or do stupid [ __ ]
prank [ __ ] on the street with
some dumbass [ __ ]
coming back i don't understand i've seen
them they're like they're they keep
popping up with these [ __ ] white
people who are [ __ ] up with like
like like black americans or latino
americans on the street like trying to
start fights yeah that's ridiculous and
then people still eat this [ __ ] up and
they go i'm a content creator i guess
i'm an influencer i [ __ ] guess
yes but then if you do that [ __ ] what
are you gonna sell
what kind of ads are you gonna make yeah
you know pepper spray
well that's what i'm talking about so
it's the idea of
what what does it take to be a celebrity
now like a celebrity just anybody who
gets used like i said this is that's
fine right but
there are certain people who expect a
love a certain level of respect like
this this girl
who has two million tick tock followers
nobody shows up to her meet and greet
and she's like why aren't people showing
up because you're not creating [ __ ]
you're just creating [ __ ] that everybody
else is creating they're just there for
the good time real quick they don't give
a [ __ ] about you they're not invested
into your life they don't give a [ __ ]
about anything that you do that's the
weirdest thing like i used to think that
um people never really cared about what
i did until i got to meet people in
person and then even something small i
did a genius brain show right 300 people
showed up i was like oh [ __ ] i can't
believe 300 people showed up to the show
yeah you know
like literally blew my mind like i know
it's not a thousand person stadium but
300 people's a lot yeah you know
and i sat there thinking like holy [ __ ]
these people actually came here to see
me some people flew from florida all
over the place a lot of people came from
like out of state yeah and you know
thinking about that and how i've
garnered this relationship with this
very small group it's pretty [ __ ]
amazing right
and
the idea behind that really kind of
stems from me just continuing doing what
i'm doing and then the youtube stuff was
longer longer form content right like i
grew up with these kids right like they
listened to these videos for advice and
that kind of [ __ ] blew me away that's
really the only reason why i'm still
doing this there's not there's really
when you when you look at like the level
of achievement that you can do on
youtube once you hit a certain point
it's all the same right million views
two million views three million views at
that point you're just doing it for a
paycheck so now it's like what's the
purpose of me doing this it's
to make people laugh to give some people
this this moment to be stress-free to
all offer alternative thought and just
to kind of live my life and see if
people can take something away from this
whether they hate me or like me or not
and i think a lot of these young social
media content creators don't have that
it's just how can i get people to see me
how do they how are people going to
recognize me do they know me it doesn't
matter what it's for there's no care in
terms of curating yourself i'm not
talking about like fame or whatever i'm
talking about you as an individual
you're not creating things for yourself
and you're not developing yourself as a
person right so like because i'm not on
tick tock um
what i've noticed though a lot of tick
tock is just reposting and just
replacing the same skit or the same
audio bite is that what it is so that's
the genius thing about tick tock tick
tock is a platform that blew up and i
and i talked about this with a few other
people too the reason why tick tock did
so [ __ ] well it allowed non-creative
people to fake being creative
[Laughter]
let's not name names but yeah
you know what i think like i know what
you're talking about yeah
it allowed non-creative people to fake
being creative yeah it's an already set
idea and trend that you just have to
hash click the hashtag find it cop do
the exact same thing nothing different
just the person changes yeah and then
you get a million views people think
you're funny people think you're
creative and then these people
will go on other platforms like tv will
hit up them like oh maybe they're out
they're really funny they go they're not
a bomb yeah because they found out oh
[ __ ] i have to rest on my own laurels i
didn't develop any of my own content my
own thoughts all i did was scroll every
day and look for something to steal
that's all they did
and that's the thing too tick-tock also
allowed non-creative people to steal
openly and to make it okay it is
normalized to steal content now and it's
okay it's a hundred percent okay yeah i
can't stand that [ __ ] i mean there was
that time like when
um
you know like content stealing was just
like the wild west across
platforms like you you put on a a
skit on on youtube
and then some [ __ ] malaysian facebook
page would take your [ __ ] cut off your
credits
and then get like 5 million views across
facebook yep and facebook didn't give a
[ __ ] like where it came from
yeah
there had to be like a change where they
had to stop that [ __ ] i'm glad that they
did but that annoyed the [ __ ] out of me
because there was that iphone five
we made
and then like like a few days later on
facebook
some [ __ ] page
freebody bit that [ __ ] dude yeah like
legit everybody bit that [ __ ] i remember
after we did that video there was like
then then the other iphone came out they
literally bit the [ __ ] video we did
just for the next iphone and then there
was like seven or eight of them i'm like
holy [ __ ] there's no integrity right i
get like like times have changed who
cares whatever it feels like maybe like
that lightning in a bottle it only comes
to the very few right like because of
that thing i was at work you texted me
like did you see the keynote speech yeah
it's like yeah let's let's film like you
already wrote out a script i came right
after work we filmed it and i was like
all right good night but then i was like
now let's let's like put it together and
then we just ended up editing it till
like seven in the morning and i had to
go right back to work next thing i knew
famous uh i mean he's a great actor now
um started off on vine
and melvin greg had this interview it
was this really quick snippet that i saw
and he was like social media is a trip
you can put your heart and soul into
something and think that it's the
greatest thing and it won't pop off
you'll do a video it'll be two million
views you don't post for three days they
forget you the next right
they'll literally throw you away
as if you never existed after three days
because somebody else will either take
your idea or you won't put enough
content out and then you'll just
disappear off the face of the earth and
people won't recognize you at all
there's no there's no investment into
creating
you know that's why i think we love film
so much
there's a lot of things i dislike about
hollywood right
especially when it comes to
auditioning filming all this other stuff
and i know a lot of people who get roles
just because they know people right not
because they're great actors not because
they killed the [ __ ] audition it was
just oh i know you let me put you in
this and that's all that it takes
there's there's crazy nepotism in
hollywood too a [ __ ] ton yeah
the other side of that though is when
you create something and it lasts
forever the impact that it creates
people watch these pieces over and over
and over again nobody digests great
content like that once and then they
just leave it alone that's true so like
instagram and tick tock doesn't really
allow you to go back and search and find
your favorite video again right you'd
have to have the presence of mind to
save it the moment you see it right
exactly yeah you know and i think like
with me i don't know how many times i've
saw uh old boy i don't know how many
times i've seen all these other film
projects right you know and it's because
they created legacy with it it's
something that you can go back and enjoy
even more than you did the first time
and that's [ __ ] amazing right i think
a lot of people
maybe aren't creating with the mind of
making something that has
re-watchability yeah that you could sit
there like because i mean it is short
much shorter content obviously on social
media but then if you can make something
that has re-watchability where you can
just watch it loop that's the [ __ ] that
really works these days too right and
it's also like skewing some i think for
young people skewing your perception of
what you should develop right
doing social media is a skill you
develop that well but now you want to do
stand-up now you want to do movies now
you want to do acting and film
guess what step your [ __ ] game up
it's a different different thing
do you think there's like college
classes on how to be an influencer i'm
pretty sure they're starting some [ __ ]
like that so many kids this this
generation want to be influencer there's
got to be a like like a path like so
there was a class i took even when i was
in college it was uh it was a sociology
and new media and that's how i learned
about youtube mm-hmm so sociology and
new media that's yeah it's just like a
whole new sociology era it didn't exist
before it's like the observations that
people are making about this is actually
quite fascinating
like
i mean just to even think about it like
this
what was the measurement of somebody who
was cool in high school
it your popularity right yeah like uh
the sports you play
um
student leadership that type of [ __ ]
right your talent or your [ __ ] class
clown or some [ __ ] or you're the badass
kid or something oh it's what's your
tick tock number
how many followers do you have yeah the
idea of becoming cool is so [ __ ]
different there's things that require
certain levels like practice and skills
they don't really matter anymore
it they don't care about that they want
to know how many tick tock followers you
have
because there's this idea that you're a
person of greatness if you have people
who follow you
but then again once again to wrap it
back to the girl who has 2 million
followers and nobody showed up
what does this show what does it
actually show it kind of shows like the
ugly side of what what social media is
yeah you think that these people care
about you
right in in a short form content sense
it's going to be hard
it's like rejection without anyone
having done anything
nothing happened but that's precisely
the problem right yeah wow
i mean that's that's a [ __ ] wild
place to live in i can
i can't even imagine how what that would
feel like but the reason why she posted
it because she posted as like a sad
comedic vibe which i commend her for
yeah it was awesome yeah
but at the same time the reality when
you're not on your phone and you're in
the real world like at vidcon like
dude man i'll tell you this too there
was somebody who uh who i know that let
me know something so when i did that
show out in uh
out in long beach i kind of lightly
[ __ ] up because i thought the house of
blues in
long beach in anaheim house of blues
anaheim was the same size as the other
one out in the west side which is like a
200 seater 200-ish 300 cedar it's not
the one in anaheim's a [ __ ] concert
hall damn
i didn't [ __ ] know you thought it was
just like a cool chill small little
space and that's what i wanted and so
when i showed up i was like uh what the
[ __ ] i only sold like 300 tickets right
but they could fill out like a thousand
and so it was like [ __ ] man
but i heard like somebody else
who does a podcast was like they were
talking [ __ ] about it because they heard
that i didn't fill out the venue i was
like did you know how big the venue was
yeah it was like for like 1200 people or
a thousand people yeah well i don't know
people could look it up but it's way
more than 300 right yeah and i didn't
[ __ ] know that it's not like i could
have filled it out either way and i was
like why is this person talking [ __ ]
that's kind of mean
right
so i heard that they did a show
uh uh uh like their podcast show right
yeah [ __ ] like damn near nobody
showed up
it's like it hurts a little bit hot
you're talking a lot of [ __ ]
what like what does that do for you like
that didn't make me feel good that
nobody showed up to theirs yeah you know
but it's like the fact that you would
sit here and laugh at me about that it's
like 300 people's a lot
yeah that's a lot that's a lot that's a
lot of [ __ ] people in my mind i
thought especially locally yeah for you
like but they're not the same are you
saying like people [ __ ] flew in yeah
so i was like damn dude and it's not
like mine was at like any especially it
was like you the only reason why you
would come out to the show is just to
see me and then both yeah and so we you
know we had like 300 people in seats
that was pretty [ __ ] good you're
gonna do another one another live show
yeah so i'm working on something right
now where
i wanna
i wanna do like a genius brain stand-up
tour okay right so
um with like 200 venues yeah
we're not
there's no way a thousand people show up
i might even be lucky if 100 people show
up yeah you know especially if i do it
in different cities yeah but still even
as a stand-up set though 100 people is
solid yeah dude 100 people feels really
really fun there just to see you yeah it
feels really really [ __ ] good and um
uh i think next year after i get the
whole business thing up i'm definitely
going to go into um doing stand-up maybe
not full-time but really really work on
these jokes so i saw your story the
other day you did stand up let me tell
you this [ __ ] right so i mean i'm gonna
talk about in the other pockets but
we'll talk about it here today too
i wasn't supposed to do stand-up that
day so
long story short my buddy uh jason
cheney he's the guy that blew up on
instagram right i bought him on the
podcast i've been trying to give him a
lot of shine got him on jk news
this guy
me and my buddy pat passed also a
stand-up comic so we were gonna go to
this venue out in long beach and i was
like hey i want to see you perform he
goes cool come through so i was like
cool me and pat will roll through i was
like pat you're going up tonight he goes
yeah i'm gonna work on some jokes he
goes cool he's like you gonna do some
stand up i was like nah bro i'm gonna
[ __ ] go in there watch you guys yeah
and then we get a text from jason and i
see this little video with my face
on the [ __ ] tv screen in front of the
comedy club
what and he goes hey so you're
performing tonight he booked you he
booked me i
was
pissed
i
was pissed bro i started sweating
bullets
i was sweating my [ __ ] ass off
because you know i have crazy anxiety
yeah
i haven't done stand-up in a club in
like four years
very long time on top of that no
material
i haven't written material
i like i write jokes here and there but
i put it in the catalog so i could do it
later i haven't written material i get
there i see jason i [ __ ] muay thai
clinches phil i knew him in the gut
right
and so
he's laughing and i'm laughing too
because this is by far one of the best
pranks ever yeah
like i'm pissed but i can't stop
laughing because of how good of a prank
this is yeah right i was like bro and he
was like well you have to go up [ __ ]
so if you don't go up
so this is the thing too like all these
thoughts are running through my head and
i'm like i meet the club owner his name
is john super [ __ ] cool he goes bro
you don't have to go up like don't worry
about it
here's the problem with me
i have a lot of anxiety but i also have
this thing where a million thoughts are
racing through my head and i'm thinking
to myself like listen
just do it yeah like just [ __ ] do it
and so like the big side of me is like
anxiety and the other side of me is like
you're ain't no [ __ ]
so this side started battling each other
out this whole time i'm sitting there
like i have no material but if i go up
on stage i might freeze up and it put me
back in a place where i was 17 years old
again and i was doing stand-up for the
first time
i felt just like that
and it was trippy i felt like i walked
into a time machine and i got to look at
myself when i was 17 year olds doing 17
year old david doing stand-up for the
very first time and it felt just like
that
did you feel like you needed it though
you know what the weird thing is like
after i processed that whole situation i
thought to myself
it put things into
um
it gave me a lot of clarity right and
what i mean by that is that
it made me think to myself
number one
it actually does bother me when people
when i read a comment that says like oh
you
have an opinion about other comics but
you don't do stand-up
and it didn't really bother me like in
the sense like i'm not losing sleep over
it but in my mind i'm like they might be
right
you know
i was like holy [ __ ] they actually might
be kind of right like i haven't done
stand-up in years yeah so am i just like
talking out of my ass yeah and so a part
of me well that was a part of the big
motivation why i said [ __ ] it i don't
have anything but if i've been doing
this since i was 16 years old i should
be able to do something yeah like david
are you funny
can you make these people in this room
who have no idea who you are right are
you objectively funny can you [ __ ] do
it and that [ __ ] was battling inside me
that day and i it kind of faced i had to
face something that i didn't have to
face before which is without your
following these people who know you they
know that you're funny so
you still have to make them laugh
but they understand who you are there's
a lot of inside stuff that you can work
on these people don't know who you are
can you prove your worth again just like
when you were 17 years old can you do it
yeah
so i grab a beer i drink it it calms my
nerves john comes up to me and he goes
you don't have to do this i was like
john whatever just do it [ __ ] it let's
go and then jason hears me jason runs up
to john he goes dave is going to go up
he goes how many minutes do you want i
was like he's like two minutes i'll give
you two minutes and i'll just you can
i'll give you a light and you can go off
stage
john was super nice and i was like we're
just gonna see what happens so i end up
doing ten minutes right and i got good
laughs like people were laughing and it
was a pretty i think it was a pretty
hard room because it was only like 30 or
40 people in there right
and i was like okay i don't know what
these jokes are and guess what i opened
up with making fun of shangchi
it worked right
dog
because like
i i mean
i'm i'm damn sure it probably worked
well because
i mean
from what the rest of the world has has
seen was just how awesome it is or
whatever yeah then if you got an asian
guy to say some [ __ ] about some asian
[ __ ] then it's a new perspective that
like that people might needed to hear
you know yeah people were [ __ ]
laughing and it was weird like it was a
weird odd satisfaction because at first
i didn't realize people were laughing
because i was so nervous all i could
hear was white noise right and so i just
went back to and jason gave me really
good advice he goes look this room is
not for you this is not a huge room you
don't have to make people laugh here
you're just going to work on material
and i was like jason i don't have
[ __ ] material right he goes say
whatever talk about your day it doesn't
matter just go up there and just do your
[ __ ] and he kept you know
he was it's weird because jason's really
goofy but he was very serious he goes
talk about anything he goes you're a
funny guy i know you are right and he's
like just go up there and just do your
[ __ ] he goes you've done stand-up for
years just [ __ ] do it he was like
just talk about anything and so i was
like you know what let me just talk my
[ __ ] and then i just went up there i
don't even remember the rest of the
jokes i said yeah but people were
cracking up and i'm like oh [ __ ] i can
still do this it's like something i've
i've been at 16 but i'm like 34 now yeah
that's a lot of times 18 years yeah of
stuff that you've tried so hard when you
were younger it doesn't go away and i
was kind of shocked that i could
still be comfortable on stage as if i've
done it for years right and you have did
you have moments where you're just like
you're [ __ ] thrown wet crazy dry
and i mean the crazy thing was i think
the beard caught my nerves down so i was
just up there just talking my [ __ ] and
i i saw what i felt in my head wasn't
what i looked like on stage
because i saw they sent me a couple of
clips and i looked really comfortable
but i to me i felt like i wanted to die
i wanted to [ __ ] die i got off stage
and i thought to myself that was [ __ ]
terrible that set was
[ __ ] trash
and then you know jason and pat came up
to me like bro you were [ __ ] cracking
up the room i was like i couldn't hear
any laughs he goes no they were laughing
and i think they were shocked too
because it's like dog you went up there
no material and you pulled that [ __ ] out
of your ass that's like
that's pretty brave
well do you see yourself you know uh
doing it again
i don't know because like
i think i do want to do a tour once just
because it's on my bucket list but i
have no inclination to want to be the
best comic in the world right that was
the driving force that i had before
where i wanted to be an undeniably
amazing comic that when i walk into a
room other comics will recognize me and
they go that guy is [ __ ] funny i
don't have that anymore
um i mean you don't need to because you
have your own audience yeah yeah yeah
and so now i just enjoy just connecting
with people like on this podcast it
feels [ __ ] different but having to be
faced with that fear and you know what
it was true because chris sosa my buddy
who was also a stand-up comedy said some
[ __ ] and i didn't really think about
this he goes are you afraid of going up
on stage
and now that you have a following and
people know who you are that somebody's
going to walk off stage and say davis
was actually not that funny
and i was like i wasn't before
now that you say it yeah it sure is
[ __ ] now yeah you know and i had that
thought before i was going to go on
stage i said what do these people know
me and they're like oh [ __ ] davidson's
not funny he just talks a lot of [ __ ]
and i never had that doubt in my head
before and i i was faced with that doubt
right before i was about to go on stage
did you prove yourself wrong
i mean yeah i did yeah which felt i felt
vindicated nice you know
nobody knows who i am in this room and i
have to prove my [ __ ] worth to these
people yeah so they don't know who the
[ __ ] i am they've never seen me anywhere
they just go oh this guy's funny dude
i'm [ __ ] proud of you man
i can't do that [ __ ] i just got reminded
i mean you know and i know that like my
worst [ __ ] best man speech in the
[ __ ] world
so
i don't know if you want to keep this in
but i um i [ __ ] saw kev
and he was at the that wedding
jumba oh really how's he doing he's
looks great he looks fine awesome yeah
um
he was like oh [ __ ] i haven't seen you
since that morning
oh my god
this [ __ ] was so bad man
i was like yeah i know that's so [ __ ]
funny dude the worst of me is like yeah
i mean at the
when when when people say comics bomb
and [ __ ] it's like i don't know what
that feels like but i know what bombing
the best man's speech is essentially the
same thing bro yeah so you know exactly
what it feels like
so like i mean i don't know if i'm ever
gonna have my [ __ ]
time you know to ever give like a better
best man speech but at least i know what
it's like to bomb oh it sticks with you
for the rest of your life but at the
same time like because i've been able to
make fun of myself over it as well so
much better it's so much better i can
talk about it and i can openly that's
how like i think that's like i like
started to talk again and like
opening up with that [ __ ] and just
whatever yeah i think that's like the
biggest change about you when after you
started going to therapy and everything
else is that you have been able to
really be very introspective and be able
to laugh at your flaws because before
you had a lot of trouble with that like
things would hurt you a little more and
i think because you were so in your head
about these things like
you know as a group when friends we
we're just laughing at each other you
know i think sometimes you took it
really personally because you were
battling [ __ ] here you know yeah and so
when you couldn't make fun of yourself
it just made it worse for you and when
you're in front of goofy people we just
laugh even more
for sure over time i've learned that
i've had to [ __ ] on myself in a healthy
way in a healthy way because i know how
to [ __ ] on myself in a
[ __ ] very toxic way as well yeah um
but when you i turned it around i mean
learning from you um watching a lot of
stand-up and um honestly so thankful
that you bring me on here um i just i
talked with an old friend from a long
time like he's been my friend since like
second grade back in seattle
um telling me that he watches you know
every episode here you know and when i
come on like
he tells me how like awesome is like i
can tell stories that over time i've
been able to just be real keep it real
and be my true self
and going back to the whole social media
[ __ ]
what i see a lot is people putting up a
representation of themselves yeah the
best version of themselves which is not
even the best version of themselves
because it's not even them it's not you
yeah it's not you it's the best version
of a person that you want people to
believe is you and it's not you yeah and
guess what that [ __ ] eats people up
inside
and and what really helped me was when i
had to go back to washington and work at
the store
like was um you know our friend dan was
just telling us telling me like look
you know racist [ __ ] is gonna happen you
know bad things are gonna happen but
he's like your creator your content
creator man just use it
and then you told me
shoot yourself in the foot before they
can shoot you in the heart yeah and that
stuck with me forever
you know so when all that terrible [ __ ]
happened at my store that's why i
constantly kept posting it yeah
because that's really what's happening
although it [ __ ] hurt and um there's
a lot of [ __ ] that came with it
the way that i could deal with it and
cope with it was to post these crazy
[ __ ] videos yeah of all the [ __ ] that
was happening to entertain people
and that opened the door for people to
come in and
like because when i post that [ __ ] i
don't want people to get angry yeah you
know because of the racist [ __ ] but then
i want people to laugh
and be by my side and know that then i
know that they have my back but that's
the greatest thing about comedy though
right and i think a lot of people are
forgetting that the reason why you don't
think a lot of comics are funny is
because you won't allow them to poke at
these very topics that shouldn't be
touched right that is what comedy is
about trying to find the [ __ ] funny
and things that aren't [ __ ] funny
when it hurts yeah when it [ __ ] hurts
and there's pain
like what people
fail to recognize
is
the
shakespearean um the drama masks right
there's those two masks the faces one
that's crying and one that's laughing
right the idea of those two masks
is that they're feeling the same thing
pain yeah
what are you gonna do with your pain i
felt so much pain for so many years
right
and you know me i had anger issues as
well um and the way i could deal with it
best and cope with it and live
and continue on was to laugh
is to keep laughing
right um i mean i i i
had my spot on jk news
and i talked about some real [ __ ]
but ultimately what i found from it when
when some bad [ __ ] happened was that
after it happened and
i can process it i can sit there and
[ __ ] laugh at how hilarious
the situation is when you step out and
look
right and there's a really
like this this [ __ ] like sweet spot
you know in whether it's content comedy
or whatever where there's sadness and
laughter yeah at the same time where
it's both and that's why also i
appreciated uh inside out yeah yeah yeah
i really got that idea through that it's
both you know whether it's joy and pain
it's both
right and when you can recognize that
you can cope much better
you won't fall into a spiral as hard
like i mean i'm not saying it's not
you're not going to
but you can deal with it you can step
over it you can live
another day
right yeah and like when you face it
though like you did like going up on
that stage facing your fears because
for real though like honestly all those
[ __ ] that talk [ __ ] to you and
whatever they still didn't do what you
did they still didn't face their fears
that's the thing too it's like the hard
part for me too is you know we always go
through that idea of you know the
concept of imposter syndrome every
[ __ ] day i could work on this craft
24 [ __ ] seven and know that i'm
somewhat decent at it maybe even good
but i still won't believe it because i
feel like i don't deserve it right and
i've done this before i've literally
married people on the spot
they're like hey do you want to be
the [ __ ] priest at their wedding like
what and i did a [ __ ] 20-minute
speech about their relationship in life
and what they should look forward to you
know on the spot i remember marielle got
to see me on a mic for the first time
and it was at that wedding right and
then she looks at me she goes
how'd you do that i was like i don't
know
i'm like i don't know to be honest with
you i don't [ __ ] know yeah i goes i
don't know she goes you didn't prep you
literally had no idea that you were
going to marry these people and you
[ __ ] pulled out this crazy speech i
wish they recorded it because i want to
know what i said
and she goes how did you do that i was
like i don't know but that's just me for
me doing stand-up since i was 16. right
like being in these weird situations
even at the [ __ ] wedding were you
bombed
i had to go take over because the dj was
cooked the [ __ ] out yeah oh my god like
as bad as i was that dj pissed me the
[ __ ] up but anywho yeah he was like on a
come down from like the coke that he did
the night before
he was like just first of all this fat
[ __ ] i'm talking about legit
obese and he was sweating his ass
sweating and i first thought it was
because he was fat it was because this
guy was coming down from a high he was
coke the [ __ ] out bloodshot eyes [ __ ]
bags under his eyes didn't know where
the [ __ ] he was at maybe he was going
through alcohol withdrawals i don't know
what it was honestly i was like yo
where'd you get this guy and he said we
just went to craigslist yeah whatever
i'm like
why
the worst
[Laughter]
and the bride is [ __ ] tearing up i
was like give me the [ __ ] mic i'll
i'll i'll [ __ ] you know be the mcdmc
and i just emcee the rest of the night
and that's just from years and years of
bombing caught stand up and just trying
to be comfortable on the mic and trying
to command that stage that's true i mean
a lot if i if i look back to um about my
behaviors in the past like
i said a lot of things out loud and i
don't know what it is but then i
just say [ __ ] without thinking it
through hey and you realize in life you
spend a lot of your time in your teens
and whatever you're you're the class
clown or whatever you're you're trying
out all these jokes you think someone's
gonna laugh and they don't right but
then you just keep trying
you keep trying with your friends too um
and that was one of the stepping stones
for me to be comfortable in like doing
public speech or
um comfortable being on camera here with
you on this podcast like it took some
time like you could see the very first
podcast i was on i was sweating balls
hey me too if you go back to the very
first podcast i did i didn't know what i
was saying
it was so difficult to just kind of
think of of content on the spot but
everything takes practice and time this
is a skill
and you i just think back to like the
times i was in a taco bell parking lot
or you know my church parking lot with
my friends and then you just shoot the
[ __ ]
and then you're comfortable in your own
skin and allowing yourself to be you
right i think a lot of people have a
tough time looking at themselves in the
mirror
and really looking at themselves in
their soul and loving themselves
and accepting themselves we were talking
about you know
people who don't like to go to therapy
sometimes and a lot of the issues that i
know that a lot of people face with that
is the idea that they now have to
confront the things that they already
know are bad things about themselves
yeah and they have to fix it now yeah
because deflecting is so [ __ ] easy
it's the first thing to do you get
defensive you you look at everybody
else as if they're the problem but you
know in your hearts of heart you you
have something wrong with you yeah and
now if you go to therapy and there's an
objective person that's outside of this
bubble that has that tells you listen
these are the issues that you might be
facing
they can't run away from it now now they
either have to cry about it they have to
be they have to confront these emotions
and now that it's out there in the ether
it's right in front of their face they
have to address it you can't just be
like oh i'm just gonna go out and go
drink with my friends no it's guess what
we said it now you know the issue you've
acknowledged it so what are you gonna do
about it so either you address it and
become a better person or you are that
piece of [ __ ] that you that everybody
says that you are yeah yeah it is the
craziest [ __ ]
mental gymnastics that people will do
not even just therapy just somebody else
who confronts them about their problems
they will do mental gymnastics just to
not confront these issues and
either accept it or become better from
it right and it's hard i know it is so
[ __ ] hard like everyone can accept
the fact that we're not perfect yeah but
when it comes to okay then let's be
better yeah i don't understand that part
but to be honest like i said we always
bring it back like we're church boys
yeah the idea of sanctity right um the
pursuit of holiness that i'm not perfect
but one day one day i will be right but
to think that way that one day i will be
would means that you need to do the work
now
that you have to get over yourself you
have to get over your pride and your ego
you have to get over um like being
humiliated
and change the perspective not that
you're you are humiliated you know but
that um you are humanized yeah you know
that um you're not where you want to be
but you will be someday and you just
have to work through it i think one of
the biggest things for me too is
accepting
um the things that are shameful quote
unquote
but not being ashamed of myself yeah
right and accepting myself and being who
i am to allow myself to talk about the
worst parts of myself the last [ __ ]
podcast just talking about my drug
addiction
but
um i i looked through and
you know this is something i don't
really talk about but
most of my friends i grew up with like
my tight-knit friends
they
they fell under really hard drugs yeah
which is a really weird thing about you
know tacoma up there within my friend
group it was it was tough to face that
all of us had these drug issues
but for me and coming out of it was
being able to talk about it and not be
ashamed of it and not be ashamed of my
fuck-ups to look at the [ __ ] i did when
i was drunk you know
and talk about yeah i [ __ ] up bad that
time you know like that best man speech
but
when when i talk about it and then i
concept it it's like i'm way over it i'm
way above it do you still have the best
band speech in your phone
hell no i wish you would have kept it
hey
oh no i'm glad you nobody can find it
please but i'm just saying dude if you
would have kept it and you recited it
back on this podcast it would have been
the best therapy ever like i would i
would shrimp up into a ball
i'd cry myself
i grabbed the bike i was like well that
is done with the speech titled i'm born
with a curse
[Laughter]
uh i had a point i was trying to say
something but it just didn't you drank
way too much you got smashed oh my god
the nerves yeah it was just too much
alcohol yeah man i mean that's and it's
at that time me being a big guy like i
didn't have a limit yeah i mean um paul
paul kim had to tell me what happened by
the time i had completely i mean i was
already like blacked out somewhere
but
he told me that
um
there was like a karaoke there there was
photo booths and [ __ ] but then what they
really had was like
bottles and bottles bottles of jameson
and all this alcohol
he said i i poured two giant cups just
to the brim
of jameson and i gave it to paul i was
like cheers man and then
paul said that i [ __ ] chug that
entire cup right
and he said yo i can't drink this and he
said meth i said
[ __ ] you man like don't be a [ __ ] and i
took it and i drank his
and then
i literally just timber
get the [ __ ] out of here like um kevin
park he was there apparently i fell on
him i grabbed him and we both fell on
the gravel and i was out
and then these dudes had to carry me and
put me in the car for me to just pass
out and then matt pecker so next thing i
know next thing i know i wake up and
matt pecker's in my
apartment sleeping next to me like what
the [ __ ] are you doing here we didn't do
anything right he's like
hey
am i gay
am i gay now
you said no i drove you home but it's
like i guess he didn't have anywhere to
sleep so he just stayed at my place
that's hella funny dude but i mean look
at me i'm talking about it yeah i mean
that was a long time ago when we were
the deepest saddest part of me nah like
i'm gonna be open and talk about it
because i'm not that person anymore i
don't even remember what i did that
night after that because i got pretty
drunk too so i couldn't remember too
much
so like i don't i just remember looking
at you from a distance and i was just
like you are four seconds away from
collapsing because you kept swaying
you look like a palm tree in a storm
dude
oh just somebody please just make sure
he doesn't fall there's there's a video
of me trying to break dance
i'm trying to do the windmill
doing a body roll
just drunk out of his mind on the floor
and i'm seeing loosen up my buttons baby
it's just [ __ ] hands behind his head
belly out [ __ ] doing the belly
it's like i have no recollection of this
because i'm pretty sure i was drunk too
so so you you were just doing this bro
that [ __ ] video had me dying man i
mean i guess the whole thing i was just
like you have to you just have to accept
yourself yeah flaws and all but and
in the worst part of yourselves like you
have to love yourself
and that's where you also have to find
the hater part of yourself
i guess when you're projecting
because when i look back too i don't
think
i would
hate on somebody who was in that
position too because i know i'm that way
yeah yeah yeah right and and that's when
i i do have to check myself too am i
being a hater or um am i poking fun
because i've been there
yeah i think we're just poking fun
because we've been there you know and
also to go back going back to the idea
of like am i being a hater you know when
i talk about new media you guys
understand i'm in media too yeah you've
been there i'm not hating on it i'm just
trying to
give you a better perception of it so
you're better prepared when you dive
into this thing right when i say like
listen not everybody here is a
millionaire they go hater or maybe i'm
giving you some good advice yeah like
prepare yourself for this prepare to
work get a second job yeah you're gonna
have to work a job and do this at the
same time and if you get lucky maybe you
won't have to do it anymore there's a
reason why a lot of influencers don't
make a lot of money right they make a
few bucks here and there and it's
supplemental and they get to save up
while they work their regular job that's
why
i feel like the ones who know and
understand it best
on this new social media age are the
ones who work acting and stand up yeah
because they know they got to be a
waiter on the side yeah how many actors
do you know that are on tv they're still
working another job you know like yeah
you saw them on csi you saw them here
and there guess what they're still
waiting tables at bossa nova
and there's nothing [ __ ] wrong with
that yeah and they're they're doing what
they have to do to make it happen but
there's a realistic expectation and i'm
trying to help this next generation and
i'm really supporting them like yo i the
kids will message me and i'll see some
people will mess with me i look at their
content i'm like yo shit's tight
but they're like okay well how do i make
money on this like i can't explain this
on an instagram thing but just to know
don't let go of your job keep doing this
and then build the business yeah and
that's got to be a bonus yeah right
because you're having you're supposed to
have fun doing it too yeah right there's
no way i would have been able to stay in
this platform if i wasn't having fun
right and then this is the funnest [ __ ]
i do
you know what should i do man this is
cheaper than therapy bro i've had this
crazy idea and you know what the person
who the person who really helped me
compartmentalize this better was
actually casey neistat okay i used to
love casey neistat's stuff only because
i saw this video where he was talking
about how much he works not on his other
projects but on his youtube videos and
this guy's a gajillionaire and he makes
his he does his own videos yeah and the
reason why is because he loves what he
does
he has done sold a show to hbo he's done
a lot of things he's been
he wasn't an actor but he was in a film
i forgot what film he was in but he has
these opportunities and he always goes
back to youtube and he said that the
reason why he loved youtube is because
because this is my space i get to create
how i want he has no fomo and other
people who are on tv who are doing these
other things and he goes
why would i turn my back on the thing
that makes me the happiest yeah and i
had it all [ __ ] up in my head i
thought to myself oh my god my you know
other people expect me to be an actor
they say i'm a good actor i can do all
these i can be in these films and i
never ask myself do i want it
i was like maybe i just like being on
youtube yeah and what's the problem in
that and you like creating i like
creating yeah what is the problem and it
doesn't matter what medium it is
joondi is a part of creating i want
our brand to be the biggest matcha bread
in the united states yeah and then
somebody's gonna look at me and say well
you weren't in a movie
but but you were but yeah yeah yeah i
was so it's like there's not even that
so it's like
cool yeah
and they'll look at your
your other businesses as if you're a
failure yeah at acting like doc what the
[ __ ] that's how you see it like you know
i run into my you know friends who are
actors and waiters and then i didn't
know they were working at a restaurant
you think i'm there like oh you must be
having a tough time no no i'm like yo
you hook it up
for real he's grinding man like you got
to give it up to them you have to be
proud for them too then you would
be able to be
able to be proud of yourself
for what you do if you are working two
jobs if you're doing two things if one's
not enough but it's still your passion
you know that's why i i've never been
ashamed of talking about working at a
gas station and putting it out there
like this shame culture based on like
what people do is so [ __ ] dumb people
have to work these jobs in these
positions like we need them yeah so when
you when you're like even
like i i'll never understand this like
when um somebody will talk to me and
they they know who i am right they go oh
i'm like oh so what do you do right they
go [ __ ] yeah
i'm a waiter and [ __ ] i'm not doing what
you do i was like why even do this like
this conversation sucks
you know
why can't it be like oh i'm waiting like
i wait at this restaurant
i don't understand this hierarchy yeah
right especially for me as a creative
you do understand that i just i just
a part of it's luck and a lot of it's
hard work yeah right but
there's nothing in my mind that goes
[ __ ] i'm a creator you're a waiter yeah
yeah like
why would you put somebody down over
that [ __ ] how is my job any better than
yours
right and i'll be it too you might even
just be making the same money as i do
who the [ __ ] knows yeah i know waiters
who make a [ __ ] ton of money to be
honest with you so it's like i don't
understand like there should be no shame
in working a job like i've had to deal
with people for example who have college
degrees and they'd rather
scrape by borrow money from other people
than work a job because they have a
degree and working a blue collar job is
beneath them right oh my i've meet i
meet so many people there what is that
they don't even have a degree but then
like someone literally crying like by my
side like i don't want to work a
[ __ ] job
i'm like what the [ __ ] you're not better
than burger king yeah they're worth like
billions of dollars they can pay you
yeah you know all you got to do is just
do what they ask like what are you
better than them like i know i joke
about this and i won't be in this
situation now because i've set myself up
but
i have no problem like if this whole
[ __ ] exploded all my junebe stuff
explode or whatever
guess what
you might see me in uber
i'll be in that uber i'll be working
that part-time job here and there i i
i'll do what i have to do yeah you know
and and like you can't be ashamed of
yourself and we'll keep saying that over
and over again you can't be ashamed of
yourself i'll be more ashamed if i have
to go ahead and choose to borrow money
from somebody and then rather work
myself and make that money myself you
and i have a friend um very successful
og youtuber
uh i i met up with him to catch up too
he told me he was doing like uh
what's the grocery delivery
oh um doordash jordan he was doing that
i mean he's as far as i know og like
successful all that [ __ ] and he said you
know at one point i had to do that
and he didn't even have shame in his
voice as he said it and it made me very
proud of him
and it allowed me to accept that yeah i
gotta work second jobs too yeah you know
it it's just a part of life you don't
have to put yourself down for doing it i
wonder how much do i do doordash right
now if i wanted to
[Laughter]
have too much time on my hands
a lot of times [ __ ] maybe i will do
doordash yeah i kind of want to know
what it's like i want to know like how
much money you can make on doordash and
then well i'm not with my forerunner
yeah
i'll make absolutely [ __ ] nothing
dude just put all that money back in
i put 40 in my tank yesterday and then i
had to fill up again this morning yeah
man that says killer
it's [ __ ] trash
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast you're supposed
to do two movies yeah
you know what we have some real
conversations and i'm i think that's
cool too
you know
well uh you could find ed at ed park vp
um catch him on all his [ __ ] socials
hit him up and genius brain every
sundays at 12 p.m and by the way just to
give you guys a heads up secret society
and genius brain will be doing our first
collab together it is one of my
i [ __ ] love this collab so much it's
gonna be pre-orders for the shirt so
we're not gonna make this ahead of time
just because it's expensive the other
way around but it's uh you guys
pre-ordered it we'll get it out to you
as fast as possible uh uh getting the
samples next week so i don't know when
this podcast is gonna drop but hopefully
you'll have it out by then and it's
[ __ ] sick it's actually inspired from
my trip to korea nice so it's a lot
about the culture stuff that we talk
about here and kind of going through the
idea of when i was a kid of not being
i want to say not being proud of where i
came from but i didn't realize how
important it was to me when you go back
to korea and you see it and i i kind of
designed this shirt that's
just as much as this podcast as much as
my pride is a secret society in that
trip to korea so
carpet is it's [ __ ] sick like the
shirt is going to be dope
uh yup jesus brain every sunday is at 12
pm we'll see you next time peace peace